[Musique]
alors moi je voudrais que l'occasion du
bicentenaire nous permettent aux uns et
aux autres seraient course de se
réconcilier sur quelques points majeurs
premièrement que les livres d'histoire
ne soient pas des livres de propagande
sous 10000 sont encore tout dit il ne
sont pas je vous dis on peut re à faire
ensemble vous qu'une étude un peu plus
approfondie les livres d'histoire monde
et d'éléments de la garde des livres
d'école privée je me sais depuis un
certain temps je voudrais quand même
dire john moore qui par l'important est
qu'ils sont peut-être des mots nous
permettant de venir au consensus que
vous affectionnez temps première donc
les livres d'histoire ne soient pas des
livres de propagande et qu'ils ne
passent pas par pertes et profits les
milliers et les milliers de victimes
deuxièmement que l'occasion kebbell soit
saisi par le président de la république
pour décrocher et déboulonner les
statues de tous les criminels contre
l'humanité dont les crimes sont
imprescriptibles robespierre marc à
saint-just tueur aux carriers savez vous
que j'ai écrit une lettre au président
un public
que je vous remets le général du roh
l'homme des colonnes infernales et sur
l'arc de triomphe et vous êtes je
voudrais à ce qu'il y ait une stèle à la
mémoire du jeune barras qui a été
assassiné par par des choix et le 7
décembre 1791 malaise alors qu'il allait
le cema zaehringen demande est-ce que je
peux terminer
est-ce que je peux terminer je voudrais
vous poser la question suivante et tout
ça monsieur mazauric rester couture st
pauli rester correct pas de terrorisme
s'il vous plaît on sait qu'ils sont les
méthodes communiste
mais ici nous sommes dans un climat de
civilité alors je voudrais vous poser la
question suivante l'insurrection
vendéenne
je crois qu'on va être d'accord là
dessus je l'espère est une insurrection
populaire
vous le dites spontanée qui s'est faite
au nom de la liberté de conscience après
une guerre civile atroce most machecoul
pornic etc
vous l'avez évoqué tweet à la houle
l'évoqué pas dans votre livre oui parce
que pornic répond à machecoul peu
importe ce qui importe c'est que après
la guerre civile atroce puisque c'est
que mes choix d'attendre toujours en
perspective il ya eu un match lâche ou
alors un massacre le 27 mars le 28 et le
29 mars le 27 le 28 ans apporte deux
mois de mars qui répandait un massacre
qui est qu'ils répondraient un autre
massacre à bord n'est absolument pas
mais c'est très la gare c'est bien ce
massacre ou de pornic monsieur vous êtes
vous êtes le seul à dire encore ça
aujourd'hui tout ou n'importe quel
historien vous donnera s'est fait largué
mais c'est pas le problème de fond le
prince de fond c'est qu'après cette
guerre civile qui s'est terminée le 21
décembre dans les marais de savenay où
il ya eu cette phrase terrible
monsieur bensaïd je ne sais pas si vous
la connaissez général ouest herman écrit
à la convention suivant les ordres que
vous m'avez donné je n'ai je n'ai rien à
me retenait pas un prisonnier à me
reprocher j'ai tout exterminés j'ai
écrasé les femmes et les enfants sous
les pieds des chevaux les signes
reproducteurs les femmes pour briser la
chaîne de vie dans ces sphères mais qui
au moins pour celles là les femmes
enfants seront plus de brigands c'était
trois ans et c'est injustifiable et à
partir de ce moment là il ya eu un plan
d'extermination qui avait trois
caractéristiques il y avait des ordres
qui étaient donnés des votes de la
convention des comptes rendus qui était
fait sur place deuxième caractéristique
s'étaient toutes les populations dont la
population civile
il s'agissait dans la sinistre
remembrement de tout raser de rayer
l'équivalente deux départements
aujourd'hui de l'histoire et de l'espace
et troisièmement c'était en raison du
caractère religieux et c'est ce que
gracchus babeuf a appelé un système de
dépopulation systématique à la formation
andalouse devrait démarrer forêts
qu'aujourd'hui fourmis d'ordre est
qu'aujourd'hui et essaimant dernier
point le président de la république
peut-être vous monsieur jeannot et vous
pourriez le faire aussi ce soir vous
ayez un mot pour les victimes les 16000
guillotiné les 35000 personnes qui sont
mortes dans les lignes avant parce que
vous on ne peut pas faire l'histoire de
l'avenir l'histoire de l'europe avec une
mémoire alors les beaux alors le beau ce
que vous avoir un bon et que nous ayons
que le demandait la mort est un vrai
débat casterman était un criminel de
guerre elle a d'ailleurs été exécuté
quelques mois plus tard désaxement les
techniques lecture où il sera question à
votre question de dépasser cela est ce
que j'ai un mot de compassion pour les
victimes ou très volontiers c'est très
facile de siècle après dire qu'on
regrette infiniment
comme vous comme moi qui ici ne regrette
pas que des crimes affreux et été commis
dans cette conjoncture nationale
on peut le dire aussi bien des
dragonnades fait sous la monarchie
contre les le cristal et c'est
exactement ce que je vous dise alors je
peux faire une liste infinie des
victimes de l'histoire qui mérite la
compassion moi ce qui m'intéresse cette
commémoration
c'est pas ça c'est de dire qu'il s'agit
de comprendre comment un certain nombre
d'enseignements de refus d'intolérance
et la papauté en refusant absolument les
droits de l'homme à l'époque a peu joué
ce rôle parmi des jeunes répondent pas
côté les six mois terminés en moto
à jouer son rôle il faut expliquer cet
enchaînement de ce qui aboutit
effectivement à des violences atroces
c'est pourquoi je souhaite vivement que
les progrès de l'avenir dans ce pays se
passe sans ces violences là une fois
qu'on a dit ça ne s'agit pas de célébrer
cela il s'agit pas non plus de le
dissimuler là où je ne vous suis pas si
vous ne cessez pas de nous répéter que
on cache qu'on dissimule qu'on est un
menteur du bicentenaire qu'on est un peu
tes petits de 4 à la mort pour pas
gâcher mais on ne cache rien du tout on
ne cachera du tout c'est la difficulté
de ces commémorations c'était une
rupture parce que précisément il a fallu
imposer contre des forces puissantes qui
refusait ce modifications imposées les
idées nouvelles et ça a été tout à
l'heure je ne mange du porc et horreur
pakistan
pas un instant je déplore infiniment que
ces morts soit arrivé simplement je
j'attache autant de compassion aux
moeurs de la world à terreur blanche
tués dans les prisons après thermidor
que ce qu était situé dans les massacres
de septembre dernier le faisons pas ce
genre de beauté bio musique c'est lé bon
j'en ai c'est la phrase de machala
constant à vouloir justifier
l'injustifiable
on risque de donner des armes à ceux qui
calomnient ce qui est légitime
[Musique]